so words are funny things
until they're not
so let me ask you about
what I think is one of the most powerful
and controversial words in the English
language the n-word
so this is a word that I
can't say
that only certain people have the right
to say
I have a friend Joe Rogan yeah who has
um
what would you say there was mass pushed
back or highlighting of of the fact that
he didn't just say n-word but the said
the full word many times throughout his
conversations when referring to
um
in a meta way about the Power of Words
especially when related to certain
comedians using those words
um yeah what do you think about this
word
is it empowering is it destructive
what is it what does it mean for race in
America
what does it mean that people like Joe
Rogan were essentially there's an attack
to cancel
him for using the word just as a scholar
of human nature what do you think about
this whole thing
it this is a phenomenon that interests
me okay
the n-word [ __ ] I could say it because
I'm black but I mean I can also say it
because I like hip-hop
and when I listen to hip-hop I hear the
word all the time these [ __ ] Ain't
dude you know you watch out for these
you know Etc
uh I heard the word constantly as I was
growing up as a boy and a young man in
Chicago [ __ ] Ain't [ __ ]
that was said that was you know the the
and that could be a reflection of some
kind of pathology within the
African-American community of
self-hatred and so forth it could be or
it could just be a colloquial
linguistic way I mean I assume other
groups also have uh their various I
don't know how the Irish talk about
their Irish Brothers and you know
whatever and
um I I don't know how the Jews talk
about the Jewish brothers and whatever
but black people when talking about
other black people use the n-word all
the time
my [ __ ] yeah n-i-g-g-a yeah you know my
[ __ ] uh that is a term of endearment
my friend Randall Kennedy
uh the law professor at Harvard
University has a book called [ __ ] and
he uses the word in the title of the
book The History of a strange history of
a
of a provocative word or something like
there's a subtitle but the title of the
book
is n-i-g-g-e-r colon and then he has a
subtitle
um I think of course
the use of the word as a slur and an
insult which is a part of the history
of black people in the United States the
use of the word by the southern racist
segregationist we don't want no [ __ ]
up in here y'all you know [ __ ] [ __ ]
have no place in my restaurant in my
store Etc
that's meant to be an insult it's an
insult to people and it's a fighting
word it's a word that you say that to
somebody it's a it's a invitation for
conflict
that said what is it that about this
particular word and also the asymmetry
of it that do you think it's empowering
to the black community to own a word
my my honest answer to you is I don't
know I don't fully understand it
it has become symbolic in a way and the
policing of the use of the word I can
say it but white people can't say it I
can say it I'm not a racist I'm not a
self-hating black you know I'm just
speaking the language of colloquial
English
that has emerged amongst African
Americans in which that word plays a big
role
but the prohibition on its use by others
and of course in The Joe Rogan case
it wasn't as if he was calling anybody
an inward he was simply pointing out
that people had said stuff in which the
n-word was a part of what they said now
he did make this statement about uh uh
how did he put in the Planet of the Apes
that one of the offensive things that he
said had a you know he walked into a
room there's a bunch of black guys
standing around he says like Planet of
the Apes he said it's like Africa Planet
of the Apes yeah he should have and he
said that's a little bit more careful
that was that was an insult uh that was
that was you know
something that uh you know if you say
that and people are offended they have a
right to be offended and if you didn't
mean to offend them you can apologize
and he did apologize I accept his
apology Joe's okay with me as far as
that goes
um in fact McWhorter and I John
McWhorter and I at the podcast that I do
the Glenn show I had a conversation part
of which touched on The Joe Rogan
phenomenon and we concluded he didn't
really do anything wrong I mean I mean
you can like her no you can hate him or
whatever but the idea that he's a racist
it's kind of ridiculous so frankly I
mean
you know uh if that's your test of what
constitutes a racist the utterance of
the word
uh then you know it's kind of a it's
it's kind of silly as far as I'm
concerned